let's give ourselves some practice
solving equations so let's say we had
the equation 1/3 plus a is equal to 5/3
what is the a that makes this equation
true if I had 1/3 plus this a what a
what does a need to be in order for 1/3
to that in order for 1/3 plus that to be
equal to 5/3 so there's a bunch of
different ways of doing this and this is
one of the fun things about equations is
there's now exactly one right way to do
it but let's think about what at least I
think might be the simplest way and
before I worked or anything you should
always try to pause the video and do it
on your own so what I like to think
about is well can I can I can I have
just my a on one side of the equation
since it's already on the left-hand side
let's see if I can keep it on the
left-hand side but get rid of this 1/3
somehow well the easiest way I can think
of getting rid of this 1/3 is to
subtract 1/3 from the left hand side of
the equation now I can't just do that
from the left hand side of the equation
if 1/3 plus a is equal to 5/3 and if I
just subtract 1/3 from the left hand
side then they're not going to be equal
any more then this thing is going to be
1/3 less while this thing isn't going to
change so then this thing on the Left
would become less than 5/3 so in order
to hold the Equality whatever I do on
the left hand side I have to do on the
right hand side as well so I have to
subtract 1/3 from both sides and if I do
that then on the left hand side 1/3
minus 1/3 that's the whole reason why I
subtracted 1/3 was to get rid of the 1/3
and I am left with a is equal to 5/3
minus 1/3 5/3 minus 1/3 minus 1/3 and
what is that going to be equal to I have
five of something in this case I have
5/3 and I'm going to subtract a 1/3 so
I'm going to have be left with 4/3 so I
could write a a is equal to 4/3 and you
could check to make sure that works 1/3
plus 4/3 is indeed equal to 5/3 let's do
another one of these so let's say that
we have the equation K minus 8 is equal
to eleven point eight so once again I
want to solve for K I want to have just
two K on the left hand side I don't want
this so I don't want this subtracting
this 8 right over here so in order to
get rid of this 8 let's add 8 on the
left hand side and of course if I do it
on the left hand side I have to do it on
the right hand side as well so we're
going to add 8 to both sides the left
hand side you are subtracting 8 and then
you're adding 8 that's just going to
cancel out and you're just going to be
left with K and on the right hand side
11.8 plus 8
well 11 plus 8 is 19 so it's going to be
19 point eight and we're done and once
again what's neat about equations you
can always check to see if you get the
right answer
nineteen point eight minus eight is
eleven point eight let's do another one
this is too much fun all right so let's
say that I had 5 thirteenth's
is equal to t minus 6 13 all right this
is interesting because now I have my
variable on the right-hand side well
let's just leave it there let's just see
if we could solve for t by getting rid
of everything else on the right-hand
side and like we've done in the past if
I want to I'm subtracting 6 over 13 so
why don't I just add it why don't I just
add 6 over 13 I can't just do that on
the right hand side then the two sides
won't be equal anymore so I got to do it
on the left hand side if I want to hold
the equality so what happens so what
happens on the left hand side I have let
me give myself a little bit more space I
have 5 13 plus 6 13 plus 6/13
are equal to or equal to well I was
subtracting 6 13 so now I add 6 13 s
well those are just going to add to 0-6
13 s minus 6 13 s is just 0 so you're
left with T so T is equal to this if I
have 5 13 Sen I add to that 6 13 well
I'm going to have 11 13 so this is going
to be 11 13 is equal to T or I could
write that the other way around I could
write
T is equal to 1113